so let's see if we can evaluate the
indefinite integral x over two times
sine of two x squared plus two DX and
try to pause the video and see if you
can work through it on your own so let's
see what is going on here so I have this
x over 2 and then I have sine of two x
squared plus two now if I were just
taking if I were just taking the
indefinite integral of sine of X that is
that is pretty straightforward the
indefinite integral of sine of X well we
know that the derivative we know the
derivative of cosine of X is equal to
negative sine of X so if I were to take
the derivative of negative cosine of X
that's going to be positive sine of X so
this is going to be negative cosine of X
and I could have made that even clearer
I could have put a negative here and
then a negative here and you say okay
well look the antiderivative of negative
sine of X is just cosine of X and then I
have this negative out here negative
cosine of X but that's not what I have
here
I don't have sine of X I have sine of
two x squared plus two but then I have
this other thing with an X here and so
what your brain might be doing or it's
good once you get enough practice when
your brain will start to do this say
okay well this is interesting
this kind of looks like the derivative
of this if this is if we were to call
this and I'm tired of that orange if we
were to if we were to call a why this
color changing is if we were to call
this f of X if two x squared plus two is
f of X - x squared plus two is f of X
what is f prime of X well then F prime
of X F prime of X is going to be four X
and this thing right over here isn't
exactly 4x but we can make it we can we
can do a little rearranging multiplying
and dividing by a constant so this
becomes 4x what if what if we were to
what if we were to multiply and divide
by four so we multiply by four there and
then we divide by four and then we take
it out of the integral sign and even
better let's take this two out so let's
just take so this is let's take the
one-half out of here so this is going to
be one-half
and so I could have rewritten the
original integral as 1/2 times 1/4 so
it's 1/8 times the integral times the
integral of 4x times sine of 2x squared
plus 2 DX well now this is interesting
because if this is f of X if if this
business right over here is f of X so
we're essentially taking sine of f of X
then this business right over here is f
prime of X which is a good signal to us
at a the reverse chain rule is
applicable over here we can we can
rewrite this we could also rewrite this
is this is going to be equal to 1 we can
rewrite this as the same thing as 1/8 I
went to the same colors I'm using a new
art program and sometimes the color
changing isn't as obvious as it should
be
so 1/8 times the integral of f prime of
X F F prime of x times sine sine of f of
X sine of f of X DX let me throw that f
of X in there so sine of f of X and so
when you view it this way you say hey
you know by the reverse chain rule I
have IIIi have a function and I have its
derivative here so I can really just
take the antiderivative with respect to
this this is essentially what we're
doing a new substitution you could do
use substitution here you could set u
equaling this and then D U is going to
be 4x DX but now we're getting a little
practice starting to do it a little bit
more in our heads so what would this
integral evaluate out to be well this
would be this would be 1/8 x times well
if you take the antiderivative of sine
of f of X with respect to f of X well we
already saw that that's negative cosine
of X so this is going to be times
negative cosine negative cosine of f of
X negative cosine of f of X negative
cosine of f of X whoops
put a blue there and then of course you
have your plus C so what is what is this
going to be well instead of just saying
F Prime instead of saying it in terms of
f of X we just say it in terms of 2x
squared this is going to be or 2x
squared plus 2 it's going to be one
eighth times I have a function and I
have its derivative so I can really just
integrate with respect to that function
so it's going to be times negative
negative cosine of 2x squared plus 2 - x
squared plus two and then of course I
have my Y keep switching to that color I
have my plus C and of course I could I
could just take the negative out it
would be negative 1/8 cosine of this
business and then plus C and we're done
we have just employed the reverse chain
rule we could have used we could have
used u substitution but hopefully we're
getting a little bit of practice here
hey I'm seeing something here and I'm
seeing its derivative so let me just
integrate with respect to this thing
which is really what you would set u to
be equal to you're integrating with
respect to the U and you have your D you
hear this this times this is D u so
you're saying it's like integrating sine
of u D you I encourage you try to use u
substitution here and you'll see it's
the exact same thing that we just did